[Music]
the coronavirus pandemic has been
catastrophic for the hospitality
industry
but covert restrictions have been lifted
and restaurants are back
i'm tim hayward i'm a restaurateur cook
and food critic i'm daniel garagan i'm a
financial times journalist and i love to
eat out today we've come to bristol in
england's west country home of one of
the uk's hottest restaurant scenes
but the pandemic disrupted supply chains
led to staff shortages and changed where
we live work and dine at we want to see
how restaurants are adapting to all of
this and what the future holds our first
stop is wilson's and a residential
corner of the city
tim kovid has been a nightmare for
restaurants up and down the country
bristol is no exception and it's not a
city i know well but we've come here
today it's got one of the most exciting
restaurant scenes in the country it has
i've been coming here i was born here
weirdly but i've been coming back here
for years because i just think it's had
the most vibrant scene imaginable lots
of exciting little places run by cool
people in interesting communities and
environments and this is one of them
wilson's was my favorite restaurant of
the year two years ago i think in the ft
because there's never like it it's just
it's exactly what you want as your local
the food is absolutely superb they've
got a real farm-to-plate operation going
on here yeah sustainability seems to be
the the buzzword at this place should we
go and check out the farm see what
they're up to i think we should
[Music]
eighty-five percent of the stuff on the
menu is from here so almost
self-sufficient can you get it that's
the ambition yeah i mean the the
ambition is to be totally a unique
experience created from the earth
bristol
and does this mean that your menu is
completely seasonal how often does it
change it changes when it's ready soon
we're going to have loads and loads of
tomatoes and we're gonna have tomatoes
on the menu for a long time
and we're gonna have tomatoes on one or
two or three courses because that's what
we've got it would be simpler to buy it
from somebody else but you know this is
that's not why we do a restaurant right
there's a simpler way so why not go for
the simple option why why do you do this
on a purely professional reason when you
pick something and put it on the plate
within a 24-hour period it is stunning
you need to do
almost nothing to it when you eat
a freshly picked and cooked beetroot it
is
unbelievable the complexity it has on a
moral level we need to do whatever we
can in whatever way we can
to to make it our little micro
difference so what's the business case
for doing it better quality of product
people will pay a premium i think i
think people do pay a premium we don't
charge a premium but people will pay a
premium
when we said we wanted to open a
restaurant it was always going to be
called wilson's initially i thought it
was all about me but quietly mary's sort
of steadied the [ __ ] mary's the sort of
the captain who doesn't need to lots of
attention she just steers the ship and
it's it's her restaurant it's her name
russian capers yeah we'll pickle them
once all of this turns into capers like
a big farm if you get a big crop of
something you put it into preservation
and storage and things like that yeah
exactly if we can
oh this is great it's a really
intriguing scale isn't it because this
is just so much bigger than
amateur gardening yeah we're just trying
to kind of because it's two of us doing
it and we're not using machinery and
we're trying our best not to use any
machinery you know things like crop
protection we have to do we've got deer
we've got rabbits we've got badger on
top of everything else top of everything
else
so when you think back to the start of
the pandemic obviously you were you were
producing some spectacular produce here
suddenly the restaurants are closed you
don't know when they're going to reopen
yeah what did you do next what happened
to all this amazing produce we donated a
lot of it to the nhs um we cooked a lot
of it and gave it away we just would
prefer to to that it went into mouths
and it went into bodies and went back
into the livestream and then went into
the bin we just kept on picking kept on
growing he can't stop this it's not like
a restaurant that you can fire up in a
week and you can close it down in a week
this this is years of planning in normal
times in pre-pandemic times or
post-pandemic times does that mean that
there's less waste in the restaurant
than there would be as you were relying
on other suppliers i mean to be honest
with you like there's
effectively zero waste because it
depends how you define waste is waste if
waste is something that goes into a
landfill we don't create any waste from
this all the trimmings go into a bin
come back the farm and get composted and
go back into the earth
i'm also fascinated by your tubs over
here what on earth are these so this is
where we're making compost teas as a
part of not over extending ourselves and
what is possible for this plot to
produce
we're trying our hardest not to bring
um anything from the outside in and you
use it as a spray-on fertilizer yeah
exactly so we're using minimal
inputs from outside something that is
really important and something that i
think people should really focus on is
small-scale local agriculture you know
it means so much more than walking into
a supermarket and getting a certified
organic
produce because it can come from
anywhere
when you think back and reflect on the
last 18 months did the the uncertainty
inspire creativity and you probably had
to yeah i think we changed a lot of
things we did a lot of things
differently we started new things we
started a bakery we started making
videos we started doing loads of stuff
when people ask me about the pandemic i
still say i wouldn't have changed it
it's given me a fresh insight into
what's important and why i do it what i
do
[Music]
our next stop is little french a short
drive up the road from wilsons
[Music]
we've got much busier i mean now it was
almost i think there was that idea of
latent demand but then it's also just
that late in demand as i just continued
this sort of constantly busy um you know
i always wanted to be a neighborhood
restaurant and we still are a
neighborhood restaurant but it's also
just attracting people from all over as
well so the number of covers you can
actually serve now on the either side of
lockdown is more than you had in the
original restaurant you went into it
with yeah i mean so we were a 45-seater
in here at its max
and we had to reduce that down to about
20 at the height of spreading people out
there so we put another 35 outside
now as we've been able to get people
closer together we're doing more covers
and probably half again our covers every
day i'm guessing this is the sort of
place that professionals who aren't
currently going to the office actually
live yeah and they're getting all the
benefits of having a nice time with
their families and living locally and
finding out local and you're you're
supplying to that group do you feel that
that decision to be neighborhood has
played well for you through this uh uh
100
the the most supportive people are our
neighbours of course you know as a
restaurant people come from
far and wide but through lockdown
supporting us with our food boxes
supporting us when you're a shop
supporting us it's all been community
and the one thing i'm really keen to do
is always keep tables for
locals that there's always an
opportunity always it's going to ask
that's interesting yeah so if it's my
wife's birthday and i live two streets
away i can yeah and it's getting busy
of course we're full on the restaurant
diary
but call up drop in come and see us you
live like we will do we will work it out
and that to me is really important
they've looked after us i want to look
after them and they're they're your
bread and butter for life
when you're not eating out and you see
the quality of what you're buying in
supermarkets which is all we all we seem
to have people suddenly recognized what
it was that was important to them in
life
and it's sitting around a table with
their with that with their with their
friends with their family eating
incredible quality ingredients and as
soon as that's taken away from them i
think people were nervous that that
would be that would be gone that if they
didn't look after us there was going to
be
this homogenous high street where the
big boys moved in later and you never
get it back so you're still using lots
of suppliers just tight around bristol
and spain and france and what but it's
the fact that i have
people that i've got relationships with
for the last 15 years i have a
relationship with a guy who's got a
15-year relationship with a guy who's
got a 50-year relationship with these
things but it's the restaurants that
keep those those alive the supermarkets
want the ease of the most convenient and
the highest profit margins whereas we're
looking for the interesting
and the and the diverse and the and the
and
sort of the more niche stuff where
there's a story and that's the other
thing i think people have
because they weren't eating out they
want the stories they want to know more
about where everything they've got is is
coming from in amongst all of this the
small people are the people that are
going to really grow they'll stay small
i think maybe we'll have two or three
sites maybe we'll have two or three but
they're never going to become enormous
but that's what's going to give the
diversity the excitement and look at the
high street here the independent
bookshop the fishmonger the butchers
we've opened the bakery
[Music]
big wine selection cheese to be used in
the restaurant the meat wine that you
sell in the restaurant wine is it we're
sitting in the restaurant
this rewinds this sort of march last
year what was going through your mind at
that point
the restaurant had only been open
eight months it was
right now there were people desperate to
sell produce our butcher our veg man all
these people that we wanted to keep
working with we also people wanted bread
people wanted flour they wanted the
basics in life but they wanted the
pleasures as well so we it was you know
good bread people were always asking us
can you make we couldn't make enough
bread for people so we weren't baking
bread i was buying bread in i thought
hang on a sec there's a there's a market
for this up here you can sell a good few
hundred loads a day in our neighborhood
this wasn't just the charitable endeavor
right this became a smart business
response to a crisis it was and people
didn't want to queue outside
supermarkets they wanted to come to our
shop and that we'd set up in a
restaurant people were were more excited
by it then we'd sort of started doing
let's sell online so people could see
beforehand and it made the process a bit
quicker they could come and just collect
something and walk away with it so it
made the shopping experience quicker and
then it became my goodness me this is
restaurant quality produce this is
incredible value why am i going to the
supermarket and then we said well
actually let's just build a shop let's
stack that out it was like well if we're
doing a bakery and we're doing a shop we
might as well do a cafe and then we have
a little let's get it licensed it became
a bit of a wine bar as well just kind of
kind of grew like that
in the middle of all of this i mean
we've gone from being a
45-seater restaurant that when i first
set out before the pandemic i thought
we'd employ six eight ten people turns
out that's employing thirty down here
we're employing nearly twenty and the
business has now a bit sort of a little
mini beast if you like did you ever
think you'd be doing something like this
before the pandemic
no
[Music]
so tim once again we've seen how the
pandemic is a crisis but it can also
present opportunity i think that's the
most fascinating part about this it's
not a great sort of admission that
suddenly rents are going to be dropping
down to sensible levels but people are
doing deals quietly you know it's an
empty shop we haven't got anything else
to do with it we don't like it being
empty uh you know coffee is great you
can put it in it's a really simple thing
to set up
do a little bit of woodwork around the
outside and suddenly i mean this could
be sydney this could be san francisco
it's kind of lovely there are
interesting things going on with the
supply chain too which has been
disrupted by the pandemic i mean
wilson's are using pretty much 85
percent of their own produce whereas
here um with little french they're
supporting the local suppliers they
didn't want to see them go out of
business in the short term at the start
of the pandemic and what we're seeing
now is actually an opportunity but
they're not just serving the butcher's
meat in the restaurant they're serving
it here in the deli as well the
community is is again it's a theme that
we're seeing again and again but if
you're in one of those areas and you're
lucky enough to have that loyal
community who don't want to lose their
their favorite restaurants who are going
out of their way to support them these
guys have got a much better chance than
those who are perhaps stuck in the city
centers where the office workers to use
the support those businesses just aren't
there anymore yes but this is the other
thing that we need to
think about in any analysis of this
which is it's almost my postcode but you
and i have been to the city in the last
couple of weeks we've driven through
central london and
it's like a zombie movie yeah yeah
there's and there's billions of pounds
worth of office space they're just not
being used and yet the business lunch is
now happening in the residential area we
see it we're seeing that oh god you're
certainly here and it was terrifying in
the early days but actually some of
these businesses are emerging in a
better place than they than they were
before the pandemic
[Music]
you